this video is sponsored by nordvpn
when it comes to your functional
training i believe that variety is
absolutely key that means variety in the
types of movement that you're using but
it also means variety in the tempo the
speed of those movements this is what
tempo training refers to essentially
you're going to be focusing on the speed
of your lifts whereas most of us might
not give much thought to how fast we're
bench pressing curling or squatting when
you perform tempo training you're going
to really put a focus and emphasis on
that aspect of your training for many
people tempo training simply means going
much slower because most of us when we
don't give much thought tend to lift
quite quickly because this is easier
typically
therefore tempo training is generally
synonymous with lifting more slowly this
has a very unique form of notation
normally this will be written as four
different numbers the first number being
the speed of the eccentric portion of
the movement so lowering the weight
stretching the muscle the next number is
going to be how long you pause at the
bottom of the rep the next number is
going to be how quickly you lift the
weight that being the concentric portion
and then the final number is how long
you pause at the top and then you repeat
but the correct question to now be
asking is what's the point of going
slowly what does this do to benefit you
well first of all lifting weights much
more slowly will potentially increase
hypertrophy help you to build muscle
faster this is because you're increasing
your total time under tension spending
more time contracting against resistance
mechanical tension on its own has been
shown to trigger protein synthesis
meaning that even in the absence of
increased testosterone or muscle damage
simply spending more time under tension
will increase muscle growth potentially
so by going slowly you can increase time
under tension potentially increase
hypertrophy as well this might also
create a hypoxic environment creating
metabolic stress and this could also
help you to engage more fast twitch
muscle fibers potentially as they're
anaerobic and need less oxygen if you've
hit a plateau and aesthetics are
important to you then going a bit more
slowly might just be what you're looking
for
another thing this does is it forces you
to control the movement all the way
through the repetition so if you're used
to exploding up out of the squat and you
might find that what you're actually
doing is allowing momentum to carry you
a lot of the way so you're not actually
required to put that much effort in at
the same time if you're just dropping
down then you're not really doing
anything either if you control the
movement and move up extremely slowly
like so and move down extremely slowly
then you're forced to control yourself
and to develop power and strength at
every point in the strength curve what i
find even more interesting about this is
that moving slowly allows you to focus
all your efforts on your slow twitch
muscle fiber the reason for this is that
fast twitch muscle fiber isn't capable
of moving something slowly the motor
units containing the fast twitch muscle
fiber are so big and powerful that they
represent a large step change in force
if you were to try and lift a spoon into
your mouth using fast switch muscle
fiber you'd smack yourself in the face
conversely the slower twitch muscle
fibers allow to add just that little bit
of extra force to gradually move
something towards you or away from you
this is why it's so much harder to move
something heavy slowly so
if i take this 20 kilogram dumbbell
and i try and slowly curl it
you're gonna see
that i really struggle
and have to put in a whole lot of effort
conversely if i do it quickly
then that's much easier because i can
explode through the movement by the way
guys you might have noticed that i'm
coming to you from a different location
this time around that being my own
office
this is the bio lab 3.0 i've just moved
in here out of the small room in my
family home because my baby is now too
big to sleep with us in our room and he
needs his own space so i've moved out
into here i'm sad to be away from the
house but i think it's exciting times
for the channel and hopefully it's going
to result in more high quality content
for you guys and of course one of the
first things i had to do moving in here
was to set up internet and part of that
means using my vpn nordvpn who are the
sponsors of this video so nordvpn is a
must for anyone who's serious about
being productive online for being
creative online because helps protect
your data so for those who aren't
familiar a vpn is a virtual private
network what it means is you're
rerouting your traffic via a server
located somewhere else so instead of
connecting directly to websites you
connect to that server the server
connects to the website and then it
relays all that information back to you
that means that the website never sees
your ip address doesn't know you're
browsing it and at the same time your
isp doesn't know which websites you're
visiting they can't see that either
because as far as they're concerned
you're only visiting the server not only
does this help protect your data and
keep everything safer which is an
absolute must especially if you work
online but it also allows you to do a
number of other things such as spoofing
your location so that you can pretend
you're coming from another country and
this of course is great for accessing
region locked content from sites like
netflix from prime videos etc and
nordvpn is the fastest available as
shown by the most recent speed tests
views of this channel can get access to
an exclusive deal by going to
nordvpn.com forward slash the bioneer
today that also comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee so there's no risk
at all
just in the kind of normal stuff people
do in office i guess the next question
of course is why would you want to
target your slow twitch muscle fiber and
there are a few good reasons for that
slow touch muscle fiber although it
produces less force than fast twitch
muscle fiber it also takes up less space
than fast twitch muscle fiber and what
this means is per square inch a bundle
of slow twitch fibers will produce
roughly the same amount of force as one
or two fast twitch fibers at the same
time although their max power output
isn't as high as fast switch fiber you
actually don't utilize your maximum
power output for most activities
including even sprinting a lot of the
time this actually means that slow
switch fiber can contribute perfectly
fine to all sorts of athletic pursuits
so we shouldn't really just be ignoring
it pebble stat student actually has a
great article on this which if i
remember i'll link to in the description
down below and he cites one study by a
guy called saluyanov hopefully i've said
that's
right definitely not
that showed that experienced lifters
could increase their one rep maximum on
the squat over the course of just six
weeks by 25.6 percent and how do they do
this by using a slower tempo and this
makes sense when you put it in the
context that we've just discussed here
and training a slight switch fiber will
give you that control and that finesse
and that ability to slowly move your
body through space or slowly move an
object through space you actually need
in a lot of scenarios we don't just want
brute power we want fine control
mixed with brute power at the other end
of the spectrum of course you have speed
training which was famously used by
bruce lee bruce lee would take his
barbell and do a regular workout of
curls and compound movements but he'd
try and complete the workout as quickly
as possible by performing all the
movements as quickly as possible
i'm not going to talk about this in as
much detail because it's something we're
all more familiar with there are
multiple protocols that involve training
more quickly such as plyometric training
ballistic training even compensatory
acceleration but all these things allow
us to develop a greater neural drive for
exploding through movements this can
translate to faster running better
punching sprinting jumping etc and not
necessarily by adding more muscle but by
recruiting more of the fast twitch motor
units that are within that muscle and of
course by building fast twitch muscle
fiber you will potentially add more size
because that's the thicker and stronger
muscle
so how should you implement this what
can you do with all this information
well the first thing is simply to be
more mindful of your tempo when you're
training for a lot of people that's
going to mean really slowing down the
eccentric portion and exploding through
the concentric that's something that a
lot of people use another option of
course is just to go more slowly through
both portions of the movement eccentric
and concentric and we've just discussed
all the many benefits of doing this the
most extreme expression of this is the
quasi-isometric where you can take up to
a minute or even more to perform a
single repetition
just try it out go more slowly i think
you'll be surprised at how this affects
you and how you feel it the next day
there are many other protocols you can
use but there's one in particular that
i've been using for a long time and as
far as i'm aware i made it up i actually
started doing this intuitively when i
first started working out i think it
helped me to gain a lot of strength and
size really quickly and it's not
something i've already heard other
people mention i used to call it time
division i think that's actually a bit
of a lame name so i'm re-dubbing it time
manipulation training which i think
sounds a lot cooler the idea here is
simply to alter and vary your tempo but
within a single set so for example you
might perform as many really slow
repetitions as you can and then when
you're at the point of failure switch to
really fast repetitions just to pump out
an extra five six seven eight so aside
from just being interesting and varied
this also forces you to use a kind of
dynamic changing level of exertion
something that you would have to do in
real life in real life we don't just
perform something at the same level over
and over and over again we might do
something slowly and then something
quickly and then switch again more to
the point though this might and i say
might allow you to tap into your fast
twitch muscle fiber and increasing your
drive that way because as we know from
henneman's size principle we won't be
able to use those really big fast motor
units because the amount of resistance
in something like a push-up isn't enough
but if you first perform as many really
slow repetitions as you can targeting
those photos fibers we're going to do is
going to fatigue them and take them out
of the running now when you perform
those same movements you're only going
to have the fast twitch muscle fiber to
recruit because you're trying to go
explosively you're cooling on those very
same motor units and muscle fibers and
of course the opposite is also true so
if you do lots of really fast
repetitions and then move on to slow
ones then we have fatigued all the
larger motor units so again you're
forcing yourself to call upon those
slower twitch motor units you're giving
yourself this more complete control over
your strength for me this has been
really powerful i'd love to know if you
guys experiment with it how you find it
so let me know in the comments down
below come back here and tell me about
it if you experiment with this time
manipulation training
i just want to say a huge thank you once
again to anytime fitness and vista who
let me film there they're so
accommodating and just the nicest bunch
of people it's also a fantastic gym so
as i said before if you're in bista
check them out if you like this kind of
training then my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
includes a lot of different tempos as
well as a range of other different
training styles all combined into a
single program to give you that
all-round and complete performance that
comes with over two hours of video
tutorial an 80 plus page ebook and lots
of bonus extras as well so i'll put a
link to that in the description down
below subscribe if you want to see more
like this hit the bell button if you
want to be notified of future uploads
either way once again thank you so much
for watching this one and i'll see you
next time
bye for now